despite the centers for disease controls  warning to stay home many americans are  still traveling for the thanksgiving  holiday  the tsa says it screened more than a  million people on friday and a million  more or so on saturday  the busiest days at our airports across  the country since the pandemic started  last week the cdc urged americans to  stay home for thanksgiving to help  prevent the spread of the coronavirus  our sister stationed in los angeles  spoke with passengers at lax  were you nervous at all about traveling  yes actually there's a little bit of  nervousness that comes with traveling  but mostly i think i'm  fine not not too worried i'm 64 years  old and  i just want to enjoy what we can enjoy  while we can  so i took the chance the cdc warns  travel could increase your chance of  contracting covid19  medical experts are also worried large  holiday gatherings could spread the  virus even more